Ecuador is at war with drug gangs the
South American country declared what it
called an internal armed conflict after
gunman took over a TV studio and
launched a series of
attacks fighting intensified after a top
gang leader escaped from prison on
Sunday prompting a 60-day state of
emergency here's what's caused Ecuador's
wave of violence and what's at stake for
the region and the us as gangs fight for
control contr of lucrative cocaine
trafficking Roots Ecuador has been going
through a surge of violence over the
last 3 or four years it's G from one of
the safest countries in America to one
of the most violent and that's due to
the drug trade on Sunday what happened
is that a lot of the drug gangs their
leaders are located in the prisons and
one of the leaders of one of the biggest
gangs in Ecuador escaped from prison on
Sunday that prompted a response from the
new president Daniel NOOA who issued a
state of emergency and sent in uh you
know law enforcement to try to take
control of the
prisons a day after that happened on
Tuesday another gang members took over a
TV station in guil the country's biggest
city then across the country really
there was different incidents that
occurred kind of car bombs police were
kidnapped it seemed like a very
coordinated response to the government
to try to send a
message president Daniel NOA who's only
been in office since November he
declared an internal armed conflict in
Ecuador so what that practically means
is that the military will now have a
greater role in trying to improve
security so basically the gangs become
military targets the soldiers are able
to try to neutralize them the root of
this wave of violence is an increasing
drug trade drugs flowing in from
Colombia mainly that are going up to
Europe and the United States they are
now moving into Ecuador a lot of the
cocaine production in Colombia is on the
border with Ecuador the security experts
say that it's actually easier for
Colombian gangs to move the drugs into
Ecuador rather than straight out of
Columbia Ecuador has really good roads
has really good infrastructure has
little security at the ports Ecuador
also is a dollarized economy so that
makes it easier for drug gangs to
launder their money into the country and
that has you know attracted a lot of
attention from International cartels
Mexican cartels Albanian cartels for
example and it has provided a lot more
resources for the local gangs who are
now controlling this at the same time
really a key factor in this violence has
been the government's inability to
control what happens inside the prisons
the prisons have become the headquarters
kind of the defacto headquarters for the
gangs where they operate with immunity
from
inside Security Experts will say that uh
what needs to be done the first thing
needs to be done is that the government
needs to take back control of the
prisons without that it's very difficult
to weaken the gangs and to you know
reduce the violence longer term I mean
it's it's an issue of how to deal with
International drug trade and then you
know involves the US Europe Colombia uh
Mexico several Latin American countries
right now are struggling with increased
to Crime Ecuador is I think the most you
know startling example of that by
[Music]
far